Speaker 1: All right, let's get into emails for
the week, remember, you can email info at David
Pakman dot com. If you have something
to say, please use the email address
sparingly because if you use it a lot,
your emails will get auto flagged into
the trash. Unfortunately, I was actually. We
were updating our system the other day and
we actually have close to 100 different people
that email us so much that their emails are
just being auto filtered. So don't be one
of those folks. Send an occasional message
if you have something to say. First one actually
comes from from Facebook and says, Could you
be any more delusional? You constantly spew
propaganda and claims that are easily disproved,
easily proven false. Then you never retract your a
pathetic joke. I have to congratulate this person.
Speaker 2: It seems
Speaker 1: almost like a legal
requirement that if you send right wing hate mail,
Speaker 2: you mix up your and the contraction
Speaker 1: for you are y0u apostrophe
Ari. This person actually got the right.
Speaker 2: You are here
Speaker 1: and they really should be commended for
that. Now, everything else they say is, of course,
untrue. They don't cite anything that I was wrong
about or correct me. They're also wrong that
we never retract. In fact, when I'm made aware
that we got something wrong on the show,
Speaker 2: I will usually open
Speaker 1: the following show and actually
just say, Hey, I got something wrong yesterday,
and here's what it was. I apologize.
Speaker 2: Here's what here's what it is.
Speaker 1: OK, next one from Chris Chris says
vaccine hesitancy in other countries. David,
sir, I've recently read there is vaccine hesitancy
in other parts of the world. I realized that in
America, most of the hesitancy is politically
based. What is your opinion of this phenomenon
in other countries? Love your show! Listen
daily paid subscriber. Keep up the great work.
It's different in different countries. We've
talked about vaccine hesitancy, for example in
Speaker 2: France versus in
Speaker 1: Italy and in other countries as
Speaker 2: well. In in some places, it is
Speaker 1: political as influenced by what's
going on in the United States. So there are
other countries where folks have been convinced
by the rantings of American right wingers
about it's authoritarian, it's oppressive,
all of this different stuff, and they've just
sort of gone with that. There is also a pretty
Speaker 2: sizable anti big pharma
Speaker 1: sentiment in in some other countries
that drives vaccine hesitancy. And, you know,
in the United States, we talked about this with
Nicholas Christakis two weeks ago before the COVID
Speaker 2: vaccines in the
Speaker 1: United States. You had a anti-vax
on the left and you also had it on the right.
The left wing anti-vax tended to be
motivated by distrust of big pharma.
I don't trust big corporations. The anti-vax
on the right tended to be dominated by I
don't trust the government. Meaning if a
school requires my kid to be vaccinated,
I don't trust that or whatever the case may be.
Speaker 2: And so you had a kind of
Speaker 1: crossover of anti-vax from
Speaker 2: left and right in the
Speaker 1: United States. COVID anti-vax
Speaker 2: is overwhelmingly
Speaker 1: right wing. There it's it still
exists on the left. Jordan Klepper recently
did some interesting interviews with some
folks in the L.A. area, and they don't seem
particularly right wing. They seem
Speaker 2: more distrustful
Speaker 1: of vaccines along the sort of like
reiki homeopathy herbs type thing, which is more
more of a left wing thing. And you see that more
in other countries as well. You see that in Italy,
we see that in France as well. So the answer to
what drives anti-vax in other countries is
Speaker 2: it depends on which country, and
Speaker 1: there's a little bit of everything
floating around. A next email came from P P,
who says, Hey David. I was
wondering if you could shed some
Speaker 2: light on this
Speaker 1: new
Speaker 2: Foushee Bill Gates
Speaker 1: email
Speaker 2: thread that Alex
Speaker 1: Jones and Glenn Beck are
Speaker 2: saying is a smoking gun,
Speaker 1: that COVID
Speaker 2: was a product of gain
Speaker 1: of function
Speaker 2: research and then
Speaker 1: them, along with Moderna,
had the vaccine
Speaker 2: created six months
Speaker 1: before the virus came
out and released it on purpose
and all kind of wacky stuff. Yeah, I can't.
Speaker 2: Unfortunately, I can't shed any
Speaker 1: light into that. That sounds like
five or six different conspiracy theories
blended together into a smoothie of sorts.
And I have no idea how they all come together.
I've never even heard of them put together
into one conspiracy like that. One thing I
Speaker 2: think is is important to
Speaker 1: consider is if the conspiracy
is so confusing that you can't even really come up
with plausible motive linking all of these groups
Speaker 2: together. Like, as I've said many
Speaker 1: times before,
finding motive alone does not prove a
conspiracy theory. But if you can't even find
Speaker 2: motive or understand
Speaker 1: it or even really understand what
the theory is. Be skeptical of the people that are
telling you that this is the way that things are.
Austin wrote in about Trump's weird sniff and
says, David, I haven't heard you bring this up
yet. But another one of Trump's big tells is that
sniff thing he does after almost every sentence.
Very annoying and a pretty good indicator.
He's spinning another yarn. Keep it up. But
I've never seen the Trump sniffing as a signal
that he's lying because he sniffs almost all the
time. Now you might say, Well, yeah, but David,
he's lying almost all the time. But even when
he says inconsequential things,
Speaker 2: I see the sniff more
Speaker 1: of like as a tic or maybe something
related to medication he takes or something like
that. And it is notable he'll say, You know, I got
home and Melania said to me, Sir, you were on TV.
And then there's the sniff there. For me, it's
less about lying. It just seems to be a verbal
thing that Trump does maybe, maybe related to
medication, but it never seemed specifically
like a lie signal. The Big Lie signals I've
identified are. He claims someone called him sir.
Like when the infamous story, the one that's
the obvious lie. When he said, You know,
when I came into office, a general came to
me and said, Sir, we have no ammunition.
Speaker 2: We're out of bullets from Obama.
Speaker 1: And I told them, Well, let's buy more
like, that story couldn't have happened. That's a
lie. The other one is, he says, and it's really a
shame. You know, he'll say, well, 100000 dead
Speaker 2: people voted and they took
Speaker 1: they took Michigan and
Pennsylvania and Arizona from me.
Speaker 2: And it's really a shame. It's really a
Speaker 1: shame. That's a sign that he's lying.
And then the other one is and it should never
happen again, or we can't let it happen again.
Speaker 2: They they took the
Speaker 1: election with an
insurrection on November 3rd, and we can't let it
happen again. He's lying when he uses that one.
Speaker 2: And also many, many others.
Speaker 1: But the sniff one for me.
That's a different category. Leslie wrote
in with a nonpolitical question. This is
actually a really good question. Leslie says, Hey,
David, love the show would appreciate your input
if a group of people go on vacation together,
would you split the cost of the vacation rental
per person or per bedroom? I've always subscribed
to per person, but I've discovered recently a
friend uses the per bedroom
Speaker 2: calculation when
Speaker 1: divided per bedroom. The single
friend pays more for their room than the couple.
In my mind, all other parts of the rental home
and its amenities would be considered equal.
Speaker 2: So why not the bedrooms
Speaker 1: in your opinion, which is correct?
You could really go either
way with this, you know, if
Speaker 2: one let's
Speaker 1: imagine not a vacation rental,
but let's imagine an apartment, right? Because
it's a vacation rental, you don't usually pay
for electricity, water utilities, etc.
Speaker 2: If you're renting an apartment
and you've got
Speaker 1: a couple
sharing a room and then a single person
sharing a room, it seems reasonable to me
Speaker 2: that you would
Speaker 1: say, OK, in terms of space,
we have a room and you have a room, so that would
Speaker 2: be split equally, even though it's
Speaker 1: two people versus
one. But you would adjust for the
Speaker 2: fact that utilities
Speaker 1: are going to be higher
for the two people. And how I
Speaker 2: do that, how you do
Speaker 1: that, I don't know. You say, Well, we
will pay. I guess you just save. The utilities are
paid separately, will pay two thirds of the
utilities, but half of the rent. That seems
Speaker 2: reasonable mathematically
Speaker 1: on a vacation. I think I
would take a totally different approach, quite
frankly, and it's who proposes it and honestly,
who makes more money. You know, there's a lot of
situations I've been in where it's sort of like if
someone, if someone is financially better off and
says, I'm the one renting, I'm renting this house
either way. Come on and you know, give me throw me
100 bucks or, you know, whatever the case may be.
That's often the way it actually goes less
than on a per person or per bedroom basis.
Speaker 2: But as a
Speaker 1: general thing on a on a
vacation rental, I lean heavily on per bedroom per
bedroom. Let me know what you think. Evan wrote in
Speaker 2: and says conservative
Speaker 1: hypocrisy about natural
immunity. David, Sir, I see many conservatives and
vaccine skeptics espousing the use of monoclonal
antibodies to treat COVID, such as Dennis
Prager or your more recent segment on Joe Rogan
supporting it. This seems very counterintuitive
to their baseless theory that so-called natural
immunity is better than vaccine immunity. Is
it not hypocritical that they are so against
a vaccine that will strengthen the immune system
against COVID, but are willing to take a different
drug that also strengthens your immune system
against COVID? I understand the drugs and their
effects are different, but from their perspective
of so-called natural immunity, they are still
unnatural substances you're putting into your
Speaker 2: body to fight off the virus.
Speaker 1: Of course.
Speaker 2: Yeah, monoclonal antibodies.
Speaker 1: You listen when they say they don't
trust the vaccine, but they trust the antibodies.
The Pfizer vaccine is now fully approved,
whereas the antibodies are only approved via
emergency use, so it's a lower standard. Number
two, when they say, I don't trust Big Pharma.
The monoclonal antibodies are also made by
Big Pharma, and they are far more profitable,
and I think about $2000 per treatment
than, you know, a 15 to 30 dollar vaccine.
Speaker 2: So the money argument
Speaker 1: also doesn't make sense.
And yes, in a sense, you are. You are generating
immunity, not simply by fighting off the virus,
Speaker 2: but via the
Speaker 1: integration of
other antibodies that you didn't create into
your body. So it is absolutely hypocritical
along those lines as well. Very, very good point.
Speaker 2: And what's the answer? The
answer is they don't actually care.
Speaker 1: They're just against the vaccine
because all the arguments they make
against it fall apart. When you
see that they're doing
Speaker 2: monoclonal
antibodies or other big pharma
Speaker 1: treatments or things
that are not actually FDA
Speaker 2: approved either.
Speaker 1: James wrote in and says Congressman
Nunez was on the evening edit on Fox, and my job
practically dropped. They were complaining
about Hunter Biden making money with China,
and now he shouldn't be allowed to fly on Air
Force One, and he was trading with the enemy.
These are the same people that had
no problem with the Kushner's, making
hundreds of millions of dollars while working
in the White House and Ivanka being granted
Speaker 2: trademarks by the Chinese government.
Speaker 1: My advice on this?
Speaker 2: Hunter Biden stuff is
Speaker 1: do not even and just just ignore it.
Like I don't. I don't really know what
they're saying now about Hunter. I know
some right wingers right to me and say, David,
you should be talking about Hunter under his no
involvement with the Biden administration. And of
course, all of the criticisms of Hunter apply AI.
Speaker 2: But maybe not all, but close to
Speaker 1: all of the criticisms of Hunter
apply certainly to Jared and a
bunker at minimum, if not also to
Speaker 2: Don Jr. and Eric Trump.
Speaker 1: They don't apply to Baron.
I guess that's that would be the
exception. And Tiffany, everybody
Speaker 2: forgets about it. Yeah, just
Speaker 1: I wouldn't even pay attention,
quite frankly. A Zach from Orlando has a crazy
story. And says just wanted to share a story I
overheard while at the office yesterday. For
context, I work in Orlando and occasionally
have to visit the corporate office in Tampa.
When I arrived, I overheard our CEO and CFO
complaining about the traffic on I-4 and how
it's all part of Biden's America. You see, David,
according to these highly overpaid
Speaker 2: executives, ever since
Speaker 1: Biden got into office, nobody
wants to work, since nobody wants to work.
There's less truck drivers on the road. That would
be fewer since there. There's fewer truck drivers
on the road. Trucking companies have to hire
people with less experience, although I thought
nobody wanted to work. And finally, since there
are more inexperienced truck drivers on the road,
there's more traffic. Ah, because by virtue of
being less experienced, they drive more slowly, I
guess, makes sense, right? Couldn't possibly have
anything to do with our crumbling infrastructure.
Poor public transit options, et cetera.
Speaker 2: Nope. All Biden's fault.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's that's pretty full
on. I mean, that's wackier. It's so specific.
Speaker 2: And it's sort of a problem.
Speaker 1: How do I even say it's an explanation
in search of a problem? Sort of. I don't even know
Speaker 2: how to say it fully.
Speaker 1: But that's really wacky. And Zach,
I'm really sorry that you're working around that,
that that kind of nonsense. Hopefully,
it's not like that every day. Thanks for
all of your emails. You can send yours
to info at David Pakman dot com. And
we've got a great bonus show planned for you
today. You can sign up at join Packman dot
Speaker 3: com, and otherwise, we'll be back
Unidentified: with you on Monday.